hello and welcome back to City skylines
my voice should be all good again or if
you will not as bad anymore and today I
should be able to take you through at
least making this really hard happen and
also a football stadium at some point in
the video and a bit more maybe probably
eventually and what I should also note
about this episode though is that it is
quite short and I did get some comments
about the lengths of my recent videos
not being as great as they could be and
what I should say about this video is
that this video is long as well as the
video which I recorded before this being
episode 10 were just recorded in one
session and I didn't actually record any
additional flying camera shots or any
real-time footage which is probably due
to my laziness I don't quite remember
but I don't really have much to show for
this one but in a way the next episode
episode should probably make up for that
hopefully at least the next episodes can
be way longer than it was originally
planned and will at least have some
real-time parts but enough about that
this episode is about the rail yard and
the stadium and a couple of things that
I should say about the rail yard is
first and foremost I am by far not any
type of train I don't know what you
would call it exactly but I'm not a
person who's quite knowledgeable about
trains so there are probably many
mistakes that I make in the making of
this very yard so if you do see some
stuff that I do wrong and know why don't
hesitate to shoot me down because I'll
may definitely very well in the future
return to this finger to this rail yard
and change some things which aren't
quite up to standards what I should
explain about my reasons as to why it's
built in a certain way that it is I
basically wanted to have a real yard
over here and I was thinking for a long
time that I just wanted to make it a
storage and also sorting rail yard but
really in the end decided to also make
it a loading / unloading rail yard as
well on both sides of the yarn actually
over here since City skylines does not
really like it if you don't have a cargo
train station and it
really easy to get into these issues of
not having enough goods available for
commercial zones but especially when it
comes to industry or farming getting the
problem that there is a lack of raw
resources and that's really why I
figured just for game purposes it would
also be easy to get a cargo station so
this rail yard is quite small but it is
meant for storage and also sorting and
also a ground part of it is for loading
and unloading things and a lot actually
of this rail yard is inspired by a row
yard which is pretty close to where I
live
I think it's actually the only really
Arden in evelyn's or at least the only
real sizable one near Rotterdam which is
quite a bit larger than this one but
it's something which I actually cycle
over every day as I go to school and
come back or at least try to make my bus
and come back hopefully and that is
something which is always cool to look
at and really wanted to have a similar
type of real yard in here and what I
also sort of you could probably say
store from this is the idea of having a
small industrial section that small
strip of industry next to the rail yard
just to make sure that it's not just the
bare rail tracks but there's actually a
bit of industry next to it as well which
is something to keep in mind this one is
quite a bit more fancy than you would
usually see real yards in real life be
and that is primarily due to the fact
that I added industry along the size of
it as well but also probably filled it
with way more props than I should have
done in hindsight's also something I
should say about this is that at the
moment it's filled with gravel and
doesn't have too many tracks especially
given how the yard itself at the moment
actually has only six strikes which is
ridiculously low for a real yard you'll
quickly see those things go into 2030
tracks I think the the one next to where
I live actually has 40 tracks something
which is quite large but I will still
make this one quite a bit larger or at
least a little bit larger as this
episode goes on because one big mistake
that I think I made initially was to add
the gravel in between
train tracks and that is something which
actually change at the end of this
episode some time since I really wanted
to add this graph of looking at a lot of
UK and US rail yards but eventually
decided that it would be too great of a
choice since looking at the Royal yard
close to where I live actually has just
grass between the train tracks and not
having to put the gravel in between them
would allow me to actually place the
train tracks closer to each other and
allowing me to place more tracks within
this small space because even though
this is a very small rail yard I did
want to not keep it to too few tracks to
be quite honest also something that I
should say about this is that it is a
small as it is since I really confined
myself to a very small space over here
which has to do with the fact that I
planned the football stadium right next
to this and also wanted to have the
University campus on the other side not
of the highway but of the Northwest's
sort of real connection which you're
looking at right now and I wanted to
make sure that I at least kept enough
space for the university to not make it
seem too cramped and also actually be
able to add another station of their
since obviously I do want to have a
station in close proximity to the campus
as well as the football stadium which is
something I wanted to keep in mind
because the main reason that I am
placing both the stadium but also the
University and the rail yard over here
and possibly a bit small retail and in
this industry at some point in the
future is because this is really the
most accessible area of this city since
it is like as like located between these
two highways and also is going to have
on both highways actual connections to
them
it is by far the best place of the city
to reach and it is close enough to the
center I feel to have these types of
facilities in here yet not far enough to
really feel like far away from the city
itself which is why I really wanted to
have a stadium in a university because
you want to get these in areas which are
quite accessible especially in the
universities
is what you would quite often see in
these newer cities is you don't really
have a university in the center of your
city but it's a more newer campus along
the outskirts of the town which is why I
figured this would be the best place to
do so and reserve some space for it and
how to actually talk about the football
stadium over here there's quite a number
of things which I should say about it
one of them is that yes this is actually
FC barcelona's football stadium which
I'm placing in a small town over here it
doesn't make quite a lot of sense I know
and it's something which I do only
return to in the future
but this was sort of a placeholder
station a stadium which I didn't want to
have over here anyway really the main
issue which I ran up to when I built
this stadium were stats I've spent quite
a lot of time in the workshop looking
for a different football stadiums but
the main issue was that most of them
were way too small given the maximum
footprint that a building has in this
game
I told quite remember it was but I think
the maximum footprint is something like
14 times 8 squares which is very very
small for a football stadium it's also
why the actual football fields without
the actual stadium around it are
decently sized but while it is so hard
to actually find a stadium of a
realistic size and this was the only one
in which I could actually find which has
a realistic size and a style which I
could realistically see in a Dodge City
the only problem being that it's
obviously FC Barcelona Stadium also I'm
just adding a ski resort over here by
the way
but yeah it's obviously Barcelona
Stadium which is quite recognizable and
memorable and quite weird to see in such
a small town but for this model itself
it is really large I feel especially
compared to how large this city is the
football the football field inside of it
is actually still quite under scaled
realistically and also the lod model is
quite low quality nor the act not that
the actual model has a very high quality
but the LOD is very noticeably low
resolution and one very game breaking
issue is actually that the render
distance doesn't work well on the
building since the way that this
building sort of cheats
system is by having a very small
technical footprint but like the
building extends out of its footprint
which seems all rights since it allows
you to build such a huge building
without additional mods and still keep
the original footprint rules but the
issue with that is that when you sort of
skim like right next to the stadium over
here
the game doesn't see the footprints
anymore but you would still want to see
the stadium but it just fades out of
render distance and so when you get to
the sides of the same it just disappears
and you see an empty cross field because
the game thinks this stadium is not
there because it reads the football
field and thinks it's outside of viewing
distance whereas the stadium extends far
beyond its actual footprint which is a
bit of an issue that I don't quite like
about it either regardless of that I
decided to at least for the time being
make the best of it at a small parking
area around it and make sure at least to
decorate that a little bit as well as
the highway along here since this is
essentially one of those highway parts
which you do see quite a lot and the way
you really want to show off your city
almost and show that Stadium that you
have which is one of the few things
which you also quite often see with
football stadiums is they are so visible
from the highway that they're almost
flaunting their looks and their club out
there but yeah this area in general can
be considered a small entertainment
sports little area even though it just
has the ski resorts at the moment and a
football stadium
I might extend it to some other things
in the future but I also want to have
some retail around this area and a small
cinema and things like that I feel those
are really the type of facility that I
want to have in this area despite the
fact that's paired with the university
it's gonna create some massive traffic
issues maybe in the future I it's really
something which I felt is both most
logical considering the placements of
this within the city but also alongside
the highways of there
now another thing that I wanted to do in
this video was to add these hedges to
these houses not just hatches but also
the overall foliage since I felt like
adding hatches and figured well now's my
chance I need to take it because I don't
quite often actually feel like placing
hedges because it can be yeah quite
annoying at times something that I
should probably note that was actually a
comments in the comment section that I
would like to return to from last video
which is about this very neighborhood
which is the fact that this is a very
new neighborhood and though I do like
the way that it's set up and I'm quite
happy with it it really is very typical
of the late 90s early zeroes which seems
very strange considering how close to
the city centre it is but in the end I
really felt like this was the best way
to fill this in by the way I will add a
bit of more older housing along the
sides of this and it's really under the
assumption that this city is not really
a naturally growing city as you would
usually see them with an old centre and
then you really sort of develop into a
newer and newer skins around that so you
get the 19th century ring around the old
centre following the early 20th century
typical retro brick houses and that's
something which I didn't quite want to
do for this city since it really follows
the more newly developed special
development zone areas there is no real
name for it in English which makes it
quite hard to explain but I really felt
like this was also where I wanted to in
this narrow space between the real and
the old city centre had a new
neighbourhood and really most of the
neighborhoods in the city are going to
be very new there's no real in between
very old and very new in this city and
really one of the reasons is because I
like both very old and both and very new
neighbourhoods a bit more but there's
also major in-game limitation that's I
just don't feel like there are actual
realistic 19th century Dutch houses so
it's really something which I don't feel
I can get done realistically so I'd
rather just skip and try to not do it
rather than go out of my way to make
something try to work but not actually
make it work quite yet also something I
should say about these flashing screens
and I'll be gone in a second mister I
actually had to cut out a quite a large
segment of this time lapse over here
because I was being an idiot and decided
to remove all of these little brushes
one by one which for some reason the
game asks you you want to do this which
is quite annoying if you want to remove
many things at once but at the end only
realized that you can just instantly
remove them with the rails which I
should have done way earlier from my own
perspective anyway that's just about it
for this episode with just a little bit
of foliage foliage in general by the way
something that I will return to but
off-camera since I really want to zoom
in on foliage and make sure it's good
from every angle and that doesn't quite
work in time lapses so that's something
that I'll work on besides these videos
just to keep in mind that this is not
quite going to be the final look of
everything anyway thank you guys for
watching and see you guys later
Oh No in any way I'll be the same